bombshell report put out by real clear
investigations that says despite what
James Comey said the FBI failed to look
at the vast majority of the emails on
Anthony Weiner's laptop which had
thousands of Hillary Clinton State
Department emails on it joining me now
to explain further is the author of that
report investigative journalists real
clear investigations calm Paul Sperry
Paul thinks her being here and
fascinated this because actually the
letter that went to Congress explaining
this was a letter that came to me when I
was the chairman of the Oversight
Committee so tell me what you found out
now about the reality that's right
so James Comey told Congress that they
had reviewed all of the Clinton emails
hundreds of thousands that were found on
the Weiner laptop but that was not true
they barely looked at any of them just
three thousand out of 700,000 were
actually individually exact wait wait
wait they looked at how many 3,000 out
of potentially relevant 700,000 emails
were actually individually examined for
classified information and incriminating
evidence well I mean it did shocked us
right it was days they told us they're
looking into this and then days later
they somehow reviewed 700,000 documents
how many people actually were do you
have any idea how many people were
actually working on this case and
looking at these documents I was just
gonna mention that Peter struck the
disgraced agent who was in charge of
this mid-year investigation of Clinton
emails he actually personally
hand-picked that 3,000 sample and with
two other investigators they went
through them all supposedly and pulled
an all-nighter ordered pizza and said
nothing new here
case closed once again so I got to tell
you as a former chairman of the
committee as the former a member of
Congress I mean how can that be anything
other than the director of the FBI lying
to Congress and misleading us well he
also swore under oath that he had the
story that there was this miraculous
breakthrough in technology that allowed
the eff
to process the Weiner laptop for
evidence rapidly and turns out that
doesn't pass the smell test that didn't
check out either it turns out there was
a technical glitch that forwarded that
effort and I was going to say I was
gonna mention that Jason that you
wouldn't when you're on oversight you're
probably wondering the same thing how
how in the world can they get through
this mountain of evidence in just days
when after Comey gave you the the final
all-clear on Hillary so now that you've
unveiled or figured out what's going on
with this information where does this
case go next is anybody investigating
this you have Michael Horowitz who is
the inspector general for the Department
of Justice I wonder if he's looking at
it and if you have attorney general
sessions just today said that he only
operates you know without any political
influence is the Attorney General
himself looking at this in lying to
Congress well
this evidence that is it really it's
been covered up on this laptop this
Weiner laptop it's still relevant in the
clinton foundation probe especially
which is still ongoing and you know the
whole thing raises more suspicion that
the FBI politicized these investigations
during the election and it just begs for
an outside independent prosecutor to go
back through this evidence through
through these emails and see if the FBI
was trying to cover-up material evidence
in this case this is I really appreciate
your good investigative work there we
were always scratching scratching our
heads in Congress the fact that you've
unveiled this it does demand I think the
Inspector General the Attorney General
himself and potentially I would advocate
a second special prosecutor to look at
this there was no possible way that that
was happening it creates more legal
jeopardy I think for James Comey and it
really is a shocking revelation then not
only did they use Peter struck to look
at that information with his hand-picked
people and they you know order
late-night pizza but come on the
disgraced Peter struck at this point
that makes absolutely no sense Paul III
thank you for your good work and
and coming on this program to share this
with us
thank you